you intrigue me wolf kissed
orphan and sibling warrior and poet
you are many in one it seems hey
i missed you brother brandley your
husband returns
bringing gifts and riches to share
and new friends i see
[Music]
we cannot stay in norway not without
fueling more war
so we push forward a new kingdom
awaits from here to valhalla
i will always be on your side to get
[Music]
always
i give you england this land
already has many rulers
from the cunning king alfred of wessex
to the war-mongering sons of ragnar
luthbruk
they have no wish to share the kingdoms
they have made their own
i do not fear these men
[Music]
nor any others would harm us
these lands bring our people hope
i will do whatever it takes to make
england our home
the saxons hunger for norse blood
let's give them a taste brothers
[Music]
these conquests have given you a home
but there is more to this land avor
a darkness unseen an unknowable threat
one bound to england's destiny
and to yours
[Music]
you